im nordrhein-westfälischen Kerken wird
die örtliche Bahnstrecke von Kleve nach
Kempen modernisiert dabei werden auch
diese vier Bahnübergänge komplett erneut
aber die sind schon bald wieder weg
gerade erst mit moderner Technik
ausgerüstet werden Sie demnächst wieder
abgebaut weil sie überflüssig sind
ich weiß ja nicht wo sie da den Kopf
gehabt haben also ist völliger
Schwachsinn das verstehe ich wirklich
nicht das ist eine Frechheit das ist
natürlich nicht schön man baut erstmal
unseren ab ich finde das Schwachsinn
erst bauen dann wieder wegmachen ich
weiß nicht warum du überhaupt dann
vorher gebaut haben wenn sie dann bist
du da abbauen wollen
2020 stellt der Bund kurzfristig Geld
für die Bahn zur Verfügung beim
sogenannten schnellläufer-programm
sollen Bahnstrecken in einem Rutsch ganz
schnell digitalisiert werden samt der
Übergänge allein entgegen gibt es 18
einige sind offensichtlich überflüssig
werden kaum genutzt etwa dieser hier er
ist nur 200 Meter vom nächsten entfernt
den braucht keiner
und so entscheidet der Gemeinderat 2021
einstimmig vier Bahnübergänge sollen
geschlossen werden damit würde der
Steuerzahler richtig viel Geld sparen
trotzdem werden dann die überflüssigen
Übergänge digitalisiert nagelneue
Technik nagelneue Schranken für
Bahnübergänge deren Schließung kurz
bevorsteht demnächst werden die vier
Querungen wieder abgebaut und dicht
gemacht weil sie ja niemand braucht
Katastrophe
sag mal wenn wir so arbeiten würden
und Abmahnung bekommen also ich hätte
schon gedacht dass man da vorher drüber
nachdenkt ne und nicht erst große
Baukosten produziert und dann letztlich
das wieder zurückbauen muss ne die
Deutsche Bahn sagt man habe schnell
bauen müssen die Bahnübergänge damals
schon zu schließen sei rechtlich noch
nicht möglich gewesen
die Planen Feststellungsverfahren wären
bis zum Abschluss der Bauarbeiten nicht
rechtskräftig durchzuführen gewesen
formal hat alles seine richtigkeit doch
in Kerken versteht niemand diesen
deutschen planungserinn
wenn man sich vorher Gedanken gemacht
hätte was man wirklich möchte wenn ich
diesen Bahnübergang nicht möchte weil er
eigentlich überflüssig ist dann brauche
ich ihn auch nicht sanieren soll
Verschwendung
absolute Verschwendung
vermissen wird die vier teuren und
überflüssigen Bahnübergängen niemand in
Kerken gibt es dann ja immer noch 14
weitere Übergänge um ganz bequem über
die Schienen zu kommen